yeah you were there for 4/20 right yeah
you chief a little the devil's lettuce
ah now honestly really just cheap down a
little bling er nah no no no I just had
a few little sips well oh you were you
were sipping yeah I was cruising okay
yeah yeah ice-cold fuzzy man yeah you
gotta love an ice cold hard one yeah
right in your mouth
oh the cold good stuff that we all know
love does no one only has the sudsy
stuff yeah I really smoked out there hmm
I will say though huh I don't maybe this
is just my trip but I felt like I had
finally understood why Americans stick
out okay one we are the only ones one a
fortnight t-shirts why are you wearing a
fortnight D shirt I'm gonna know wasn't
target I had to buy three like I feel
like everywhere has a Walmart like in
Europe its Primark or like Asda like
they have [ __ ] clothes but I feel
like we're the only ones with the triple
XL fit shame you know we were the only
ones with like Mountain Dew t-shirts and
like I don't feel like you see a lot of
novelty t-shirts outside of like a
tourist shop like I feel like Americans
are the only ones wearing like I'm with
stupid yeah I'm saying yeah yeah and the
boardwalk t-shirts are a big thing yeah
here yeah you don't really find that
elsewhere I don't feel like no like
property of mic yeah like that that and
we're always talking about I feel like
what we have better than somewhere else
like this dude I walked past a coffee
shop I didn't know this that THC
concentrate mm-hmm is uh is a hard drug
in the Netherlands okay because like
whatever it's like wax and stuff yeah
it's considered a constant so whatever
and so you can't find it anywhere and so
you only smoke dry herb and it stood I
walk past his coffee shop he's got a pen
and he's like waving it like to someone
he hands it to someone and I'm picking
up on the conversation because Elena
Stefan in some stores I'm just listening
and this this dude from answer name it's
like a local was holding the pen and
he's like visibly tense like he he's
holding in a way that's so unnatural and
it was like yeah I take it on the plane
I take it everywhere with me it's so
easy to hide and the guy kind of gives
him like a nervous head nod and he's
gesturing it back and the guy is just
still talking he's like oh man it's so
convenient you don't want to hit it and
the dude like shakes his left hand like
no no please and he's like oh I guess
this is a federal court he's like please
take it back and the dude just rips he's
like oh man I mean it hey it's great
dude just kind of like okay sure like
puts it here like a headphone back in
like turn away from him and the dude
just sat there and that's when I left
what like only I feel like only us are
doing that [ __ ] yeah like I got these
hard ass drugs like in public basically
yeah but that's obvious is him that's
not a hard ass drug to us yeah I know
but like why what do you expect I guess
I don't know I just felt like he didn't
pick up on any cue yeah but the dude was
like please get this the [ __ ] Adam I
mean wouldn't when weed is supposedly
legal there why would any true any form
of weed not be legal that's pretty weird
yeah no I
you can't of 8 because it's concentrated
uh-huh yeah just weird yeah maybe I'm
just being as being a nerd about it like
you should know the laws before waiting
here I'm just paranoid of like getting
on a plane like bringing weed to Asia
I've watched like a ton of those videos
like dude arrested you know now in jail
for twenty five thousand lifes yeah
death by firing squad or whatever yeah
just return Indonesia if you get caught
with drugs you just die yeah I think you
Philippines is like that too now hmm if
they find drugs they just eviscerate
your ass that's crazy yeah yeah [ __ ]
a that dank
where what's going on hey where's the
gun floor dude get on your knees
wait what's out dude no like it's like
you can have it I don't want it that bad
like I'm not I have more
[Laughter]
I don't understand what's going on why
you so pissed off it's just we dude it
grows in the earth [ __ ] natural
dude duh it's not even like a drug
anymore
you just got ten thousand years in
prison yeah I don't even I'm who even
lives that long are you the ones that
are high cuz like you can't even be
alive that long dude so like who's the
real idiot here like nice good one
Nathan [ __ ] bozo over here yeah yeah
yeah here's a dunce cap look in ten
thousand years okay there ya know what
am i an alien oh you're putting a
[ __ ] Mountain in prison dude you
putting a glacier in prison cuz that's
the only thing alive for like ten
thousand years in space thanks Brad nice
yeah what did you take some some of this
asset I have in my backpack alright so
maybe I can't be too critical America I
think at that point I was just looking
for something to like hate on but the
dudes persona just pissed me off yeah ah
man I mean ignorant American is a great
this is a great like persona I imagine
him getting like he's like going to jail
like some cop walks by and he's like Oh
have you seen this before and he's like
what's that yeah
what a steve-o Woodside's I'll
concentrate dude it's the [ __ ] it's
the [ __ ] in LA hey just be a legal name
of it
oh it's THC concentrate this stuff is
great it's all the rage back at home you
can take this thing anywhere you could
take it on the plane inch behind your
back what what do you think I wonder do
we sound to everyone else like
commercials but I mean like I feel like
that's the way we talk almost like
that's like ignorant American like
reading out like a label yeah
that's how we know things yeah yeah yeah
THC concentrate it's great it's all the
rage
just like permanently recommending
brands all the time I've been feeling
too good lately
oh man will used to try xanax now I know
I know there's a lot of stigmas about
xanax but let me tell you
[Music]